We talked a bit about different
monetization models in the last lesson,
but let's refresh your
memory with the highlights
of some of the most popular models.
>> First, there are ads,
serving advertisements provide a way
to make money while you are giving
your content or app for free.
Ads are very popular on the Web,
but they aren't the only model.
Let's see another common
way to make money.
>> There's also
the one-time charge model.
Now in this model, it's similar
to what you would experience in
the real world if you went
to a brick and mortar store.
You go to a shop, pay a certain
amount to the shopkeep, and
you walk away with a t-shirt, let's say.
Now in apps you can do this
in two different ways.
First you can charge a fixed price.
So the user pays a price, and
they can download the app.
Or you can charge a price
after a trial period.
Now in both cases there are two things
that you want to pay attention to.
One, make sure that payment is quick and
easy, and
it doesn't require the user to log in.
Second, use an established
payment model, Stripe,
PayPal, GooglePay,
ApplePay, what have you.
This will make sure that your
users have a convenient and
consistent checkout flow.
>> The subscription model is another
option there are many cases where
we wish to sell our service
on a monthly or yearly basis.
The big advantage that made this
model so popular is the fact that
you get to earn more due to the increase
in the lifetime value of your users.
And they feel more comfortable
because in that pay-as-you-go model
they got full control on their expenses.
>> Lastly, there are in-app payments,
and this is
a very popular model these days, as it
combines two main user preferences.
Free apps as the starting point, and
then a way to monetize on that user
after they've decided that
your products worth it.